back of the village site has invited
over a great local cook called yaa
so was here Madame nice to meet you too
she's going to show me the Thai way to
serve oysters and an amazing fish soup
so we're gonna make uh you will let her
make some some fun some yeah lovely a
classic normally we break bang bang bang
bang you hit them yes
see ya that was amazing Oh amazing
that's right we have to bang yes right
yeah there's no need for knife skills
with yars tom some soup into the pot
yeah the lemongrass onions and turmeric
will form a classic Thai aromatic stock
so that's just plain water in there
plain water she then adds some fresh
local fish heads in fish sauce
yes we're not cheap a little bit cheaper
sugar yeah
and then this one and finally an
essential sudden sour ingredient palm
vinegar Oh trees born 3 spoons good from
here all sour and spicy so that's the
main characteristics of the southern
Thai cuisine yes hot and sour yeah
the final part of the fishy feast is a
delicious dipping sauce for oysters
bang bang until smoothies together it
starts with a paste of course made of
garlic coriander root chili and salt
Marvin beer garlic chili chili sugar
sauce sugar then limes and fish sauce
and that's the dipping sauce done my
part that or need more chili a little
bit yeah nothing of chili huh I can't
wait to taste our efforts
first up oysters and dipping sauce no
delicious pretty nice yeah really good
I'm finally the fish soup Tom some soup
delicious you frigging mmm very very
nice
thank you so much those oysters were
delicious thank you